>> TEXAS SENATE SECOND BUSLOAD
OF MIGRANTS TO THE WINDY CITY
AND IS SHOWING NO SIGNS OF
STOPPING.
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT FIRST
ACCUSED TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT OF RACISM
AND NOW SHE'S ATTACKING HIS
FAITH.
>> HE'S MANUFACTURING A HUMAN
CRISIS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
IT'S DECIDEDLY UNPATRIOTIC AND
UN-AMERICAN.
I UNDERSTAND THE PRESSURES THAT
THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS AND SOME OF
THE OTHER BORDER STATES ARE
UNDER.
WE SEE THAT ON A DAILY BASIS.
BUT THE THING TO DO IS NOT THIS.
HE PROFESSES TO BE A CHRISTIAN,
THIS IS NOT THE CHRISTIANITY AND
THE TEACHINGS OF BIBLE THAT I
NOW.
>> Harold: ABBOTT RESPONDING
TO LIGHTFOOT'S COMMENTS BY
NOTING THE REAL PROBLEM IS
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT IS ATTACKING
TEXAS INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THE
REAL CAUSE OF THE BORDER CRISIS.
HIS INACTIONS OF PUTTING TEXANS
LIVES AT RISK AND OVERWHELMING
OUR COMMUNITIES.
MEANWHILE ERIC ADAMS MAKE GOOD
ON THIS WORD ON SENDING
NEW YORKERS TO THE TEXAS BORDER
AFTER ABBOTT BUS NEARLY 2,000
MIGRANTS TO THE BIG APPLE.
A DELEGATION OF NYC OFFICIALS
ARE CURRENTLY VISITING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BE THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE CALLING IT A FACT-FINDING
MISSION.
IF YOU WERE ADVISING HIM, DANA,
IS THIS SOMETHING YOU WOULD HAVE
DEVISED A LONG TIME AGO?
SPEWING FROM THE VERY, VERY
FIRST DAY.
ERIC ADAMS WE HAVE HEARD -- I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TRUE OR NOT,
WE'VE HEARD HE HAS ASPIRATIONS
FOR HIGHER OFFICE.
PRESUMABLY YOU WANT TO WIN
OUTSIDE OF NEW YORK CITY WHICH
MEANS YOU MIGHT HAVE TO LEAVE
MANHATTAN AND GO TO THE BORDER
AND SEE IT FOR YOURSELF.
SO THE FIRST DAY I WOULD SET
GOVERNOR, I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT FOR MYSELF.
CAN I COME DOWN HERE WHEN WE GO
SEE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS TO THEM ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND SEE IF WE TRY TO FORGE
A COMPROMISE AN END BE LEADERS.
INSTEAD THEY JUST COMPLAIN, THEY
CALLED HIM ALL SORTS OF NAMES.
I ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW HOW HE
SAYS THAT GREG ABBOTT IS
MANUFACTURING A CRISIS.
IS SHE EVER GOING TO GET MAD AT
KAMALA HARRIS.
SHE SAID SHE WAS GONNA DEAL WITH
THE ROOT CAUSES.
NOBODY IS MAD AT THEM.
LORI LIGHTFOOT SAID I DO
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE PRESSURES
THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS ARE FEELING.
WELL GREG ABBOTT IS JUST TAKING
THAT PRESSURE AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET SOME
ATTENTION SO PEOPLE WILL PAY
ATTENTION TO THE PROBLEM.
HE'S FINALLY FIGURED OUT A WAY
TO DO THAT.
I DON'T THINK HE COULD PAY FOR
MORE HELPFUL OPPOSITION THEN THE
FAR LEFT HIGH CRIME MAYOR OF
CHICAGO.
SHE IS THE ONE THAT'S BASICALLY
GETTING MORE OF US TO PAY
ATTENTION.
AND THE FINAL THING I WOULD SAY
IS THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
CHRISTIANITY, WHY ISN'T SHE MAD
AT THE COYOTES?
WISE AND SHE MAD AT THE DRUG
CARTELS?
WHY ISN'T -- THAT'S THE
ANTI-CHRISTIAN THING.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS PROVIDING
THEM SHELTER, TRANSPORTATION,
AND THE ABILITY TO GO TO A PLACE
THAT SUPPOSEDLY A SANCTUARY
CITY.
BUT IF YOU'RE GOING TO RETWEET
IT AND WHERE THE T-SHIRT THAT
YOU ARE A SANCTUARY CITY, YOU
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO
THAT.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO IT,
MAYBE TRY TO BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
>> Harold: JESSE?
>> Jesse: HAVE SENDING A FEW
MIGRANTS ON A BUS TO JOE CHICAGO
IS ANTI-CHRISTIAN AND JOE BIDEN
IS THE ANTICHRIST PAID HE'S LOST
MILLIONS OF MIGRANTS ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
THEY DROPPED THE HAITIAN -- THE
CENTRAL AMERICANS NATIONS ARE
DELIVERED TO TENNESSEE,
MASSACHUSETTS, INDIANA,
MICHIGAN, NORTH CAROLINA,
GEORGIA, KENTUCKY, AND ALSO TO
DALLAS AND HOUSTON.
I MEAN SOME OF THE ILLEGALS GET
LUCKY.
THEY GET TO GO TO
WEST PALM BEACH, OTHERS HAVE TO
GO TO NEWARK, NEW JERSEY.
SOME OF THEM BITING BUSES TO
L.A., WHICH IS DANGEROUS.
HOPEFULLY THEY DON'T GET ANY
CASTINGS.
THEN HE FLIES THEM TO NEW YORK.
NO SUPPLY CHAIN PROBLEMS WITH
THAT BID THEY ARE COMING IN ON
CONVEYOR BELTS BASICALLY.
LOOK, THE BUSES AREN'T EVEN
ELECTRIC, HAROLD.
THEY ARE DESTROYING THE BORDER
AND THE OZONE LAYER.
THEY ARE ALL NICE AND THEIR
CONDITION SO IF YOU LIVE IN ERIC
AND FLORIDA THE DEMOCRATS WANT
YOU TO -- YOU COULD GET BABY
FORMULA.
GOOD LUCK FINDING IT HERE.
AND THEY'RE GIVING THEM FREE
PHONES TOO.
ARE THEY TRACKING THEM WITH
THEIR PHONES?
NO.
ARE THEY HACKING THE PHONES TO
GET INTEL ON THE CARTELS?
NO.
ANYBODY WITH A BRAIN KNOWS
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO BUT JOE BIDEN ONLY VIOLATES
THE PUCK -- AFTER ONE OF
MIGRANTS GOING TO CHICAGO,
CHICAGO IS MY GO-TO COUNTRY.
THEY BETTER BE CAREFUL WHEN WE
GO OUT AFTER MIDNIGHT TO GET A
SANDWICH.
ALSO DON'T GO TO ANY BEARS
GAMES.
WHAT THEY WILL SEE ON THAT
FIELD, NOTHING LIKE ANYTHING
THEY'VE SEEN IN THE NORTHERN
TRIBAL.
>> Harold: YOUR HONOR, THIS
SEEMS LIKE A SHREWD MOVE ON THE
PART OF THE GOVERNOR TO DO THIS.
AS IT CAN BRING ENOUGH ATTENTION
TO PREACHIEVE SOMETHING THAT
DANA SAID IN TERMS OF GETTING
THEM TO GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE
AND SAYING THIS IS BEING DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
>> Jeanine: I THINK IT'S GONNA
BRING ATTENTION TO IT.
THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS DO
THESE PEOPLE REALIZE HOW CRAZY
THEY SOUND?
DOES LORI LIGHTFOOT AND
MAYOR ADAMS AND THE REST OF
THEM -- LIGHTFOOT SAYING HE'S
MANUFACTURING A CRISIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHY DON'T YOU GO DOWN TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND TAKE A LOOK
AT THE CRISIS DOWN THERE.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
WILL IT RESULT IN SOMETHING
GOOD?
IT MAY RESULT IN SOMETHING GOOD.
RIGHT NOW MAYOR LIGHTFOOT IS
LOOKING FOR DONATIONS.
SHE IS LOOKING FOR PEOPLE TO
GIVE HER MONEY SO SHE CAN TAKE
CARE OF THE ILLEGALS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT YOU CAN
SAY THAT ABBOTT IS BEING KIND.
HE'S SAVING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MONEY BY SPENDING
$30 MILLION IN THE
TRANSPORTATION OF THESE
ILLEGALS.
THE CHRISTIAN THING REALLY
BOTHERED ME WITH LORI LIGHTFOOT.
YOU KNOW THE HUMOR IS GREAT BUT
DON'T SAY THAT HE'S UNCHRISTIAN
BECAUSE HE'S DOING THAT, AND THE
UNCHRISTIAN THING IS THE
TRAFFICKING COMMITS THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, IT'S THE RAPE TREES
AND I'VE SEEN THEM MANY TIMES
WHEN I'VE GONE DOWN THERE.
IT'S ALSO THE REPLACEMENT OF THE
CARTELS ON THE NATION IS
PLANNING ON KILLING US WITH
FENTANYL, THAT'S UNCHRISTIAN.
>> Harold: SHOULD WE DO A SHOW
DOWN THERE?
>> Jeanine: THAT'S A GREAT
IDEA.
>> Greg: AND LUNA SAY YES NOW
BUT THEN PRIVATELY NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT IS SO STUPID.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THERE ARE NO
BUSES IN THE BIBLE.
WHERE DID SHE GET THIS STUPID
ANALOGY?
YOU KNOW YOU'VE LOST WHEN YOU
COME OUT SWINGING WITH AN
ANTI-CHRISTIAN AND SALT WHEN YOU
NEVER REALLY MENTION
CHRISTIANITY AS A BENEFIT EVER
BEFORE.
IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A
CHRISTIAN IS PUTTING A SIGN
OUTSIDE YOUR HOTEL SAYING NO
ROOM AT THE END WHEN YOU'VE BEEN
BOASTING ABOUT HOW ANYBODY COULD
COME TO THE END AND STAY FOR
FREE, NOW WHEN THEY COME BE LIKE
I DON'T WANT THEM THERE.
IT'S LIKE YOUR SANCTUARY.
YOU GOT WHAT YOU WANT.
IT'S LIKE ME COMPLAINING AFTER
DANA GIVING ME A CASE OF WINE
AND I'M UPSET BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO PUT IT.
IT DOES GO BACK TO THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE HAVE TO RECONCILE TWO
COMPETING ECONOMIC FORCES.
THIS IS WHERE I STARTED TO TALK
LIKE HAROLD.
SPEAKER YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE TWO COMPETING ECONOMIC
FORCES.
WE HAVE MASS MIGRATION AND A
WELFARE STATE.
IF YOU WANT A WELFARE STATE THE
MODEL ISN'T SUSTAINABLE.
IF YOU CAN MAKE THE MODEL
PROVIDED ONLY BY THE CITIZENS
AND THEN YOU C